it is said hello everyone I'm Brent Goff
in Berlin you know big tobacco imagine
big weed the new high over legal
marijuana that and more today it's time
to talk not on our shores Australia has
a new policy to deflect asylum seekers
send them to another country today we'll
talk about the pros and cons of
outsourcing management of the boat
people well if you think the Netherlands
is the land of plenty for pot users let
me redirect you to South America Uruguay
is set to become the first country where
you can grow sell buy and use marijuana
legally joints could become as
mainstream and cigarettes and does this
mean at the beginning of the end of the
drug war and if you didn't know that a
major national election is just around
the corner here in Germany will join the
club it's not even chitchat material
here uncle America once another term as
Chancellor of Germany you see right
there but she'll have to convince an
unprecedented number of people to make
the effort in vote political apathy at
an all-time high in Germany what will it
take to get voters excited again well
I've invited three people today to talk
argue and pry apart these headlines my
first guest claim to fame so far is I
guess I have to say this is being young
and naive he is a journalist who has
gotten a lot of attention with an online
interview series that's called young and
naive t lo youngest with us today till
you've got some ideas about why Germans
have lost their mojo when it comes to
politics and we're going to talk about
that with you a little bit later on in
the show my second guest was at the
frontline in the late 60s when a
generation became associated with sex
drugs and rock and roll I'm happy to
welcome one of the original hippies
Reiner Lang Hans he's the
founder of communi is it was the first
politically motivated commune here in
Germany mr. Lang Hans um you were open
about enjoying a joint back then I'm
today though your opinions on marijuana
and drugs a little bit different and
they'll help us understand what Uruguay
could mean for the rest of the world so
glad to have you on the show today and
my next guest says that Australia's
asylum policy is designed to stop a
flood of human trafficking victims I'm
happy to welcome to the show the
ambassador of Australia to Germany mr.
Peter tesh he says that the policy is
telling asylum seekers that you can't
simply pick Australia as your
destination mr. teshon you say that it
might also be a good idea for Europe but
this notion of sending boat people to
another country Papa New Guinea is it a
morally sound one is it morally sound to
stand idly by and watch unscrupulous
profit ears people smugglers willing to
exploit vulnerable desperate people
taking the money putting them on rounds
shackled boats and just sending them off
into the great blue unknown not caring
whether they drown on route to the
better future that they seek all right
well I'm going to pick up on that in a
moment a lot of questions they asked
about that the United Nations does not
approve of how Australia is dealing with
the boat people under the new policy
asylum seekers headed for Australia will
end up in Papua New Guinea to be
resembled the UN High Commission for
Refugees says that there are significant
shortcomings in how Papua New Guinea
processes asylum seekers in short the UN
is concerned that Australia is simply
pushing people from one dangerous
situation into another since 2001 at
least a thousand people have died while
trying to reach Australia's indian ocean
territory of christmas island in
unseaworthy boats
more than 15,000 asylum seekers have
arrived by boat in Australian territory
so far this year Australia's government
has responded by implementing what it
calls its new offshore resettlement
program Papua New Guinea and the tiny
island state of Nauru are receiving
hundreds of millions of euros to deal
with the unwanted immigrants if you are
seeking to take the dangerous passage by
boat my message as Prime Minister of
Australia is simply this don't while
australia's leadership says these
agreements are aimed at combating human
smugglers critics say Australia is
shirking its obligations and outsourcing
its immigration problem to developing
nations ambassador why not spend the
money on a detention facility in
Australia or if you're going to spend
all the money that you're spending in
Papua New Guinea why not go to countries
where you're getting most of these
asylum seekers and give them good boats
so that they can come over to Australia
safely the thing people shouldn't lose
sight of in this discussion is that
Australia has in fact increased vut
annual intake of humanitarian migrants
what we're saying is there is a need to
tackle unauthorized maritime arrivals
there is a need to tackle the scourge of
people smuggling that involves national
regional and international measures why
does why are you involving a third
country and this you have the country of
origin for these people you have
Australia and now you have Papua New
Guinea why deflect them to another
country I mean you are outsourcing you
don't want to have them on Australian
soil it's not a question of saying we
don't want to have asylum seekers on
Australian soil what we need is a
multi-tiered approach to tackling the
problem of people smuggling this is not
directed at asylum seekers this is not
directed at genuine asylum seekers who
are using orderly established processes
under the UNHCR or the IO ever the way
about you're trying to improve their
well-being or flee persecution if
someone is a boat person and wants to
come to Australia they're going to end
up in Papua New Guinea now how can you
be sure that the process is in place to
determine whether
these people are true asylum seekers and
if they are and want to go to Australia
you're closing the door to them you're
saying they cannot come to Australia if
they are asylum seekers and are fleeing
persecution their intention their
ambition is to get to a country of first
asylum that does not necessarily mean
that it is Australia our Foreign
Minister has spoken of economic my team
better but M variables are economic
migrants if people want to choose their
destination then it makes you question
are they fleeing persecution or are they
seeking to improve their lives and
well-being both equally valid objectives
the question is how do you pursue those
objectives through an orderly system of
migration which is championed and
supported by institutions such as the
UNHCR and the IOM or by simply seeking
out shady characters who are willing to
pocket your money and put your lives in
Greece you've got authorities to fight
trafficking and I'll asked the other
gentleman at the table here but I mean
it's just human nature that people in
that part of the world are going to want
to go to Australia you know you are one
of the richest countries there and I can
imagine that if we were asylum seekers
if we were refugees we would want a
ticket to the best place possible right
absolutely so same holds true for German
64,000 asylum seekers arrived in Germany
last year ask the german taxpayers and
voters should people should governments
should migration systems be undermined
simply to accommodate the desires of
people and to support those who would
seek to profit from them right what do
you think about it there's this policy I
mean you come from a completely
different era when people were
socialized about about human rights and
about looking at the other what's
Australia doing I would say they should
better the conditions in the home
countries of these people so they must
not flee from them and after that the
question arises
this coming to Australia to Germany also
from Africa and arcade and I would say
that's coming of this bad situation of
these countries they are coming from and
that's the trade conditions we are happy
they're coming they're coming from bad
places but neither are they being sent
to a place that's not exactly the best
place Papa New Guinea right well I don't
know much about it but it doesn't sound
like the best place and you what you
were just mentioning human rights I
think it's human right to choose
wherever you want to live in in the
world because he the greatest luck as a
human being is to be born in a place
like Australia Australia saying that
that is not a human right Australia is
saying that you said you interrupt you
right there that is not what Australia
is saying Australia maintains a very
deliberate very well-structured orderly
migration program we are one of a very
small number of countries in the world
that actively advocates migration to
Australia you see these women cannot in
relation to asylum seekers and
humanitarian cases in close cooperation
with UNHCR in the IOM the government is
absolutely satisfied as a long-standing
member of these institutions that what
we are doing is consistent with our
obligations which is to ensure effective
protection for asylum seekers here you
assured any people will be assured that
they will not be returned to a country
from which they are fleeing persecution
can't but can you assure that these the
people when they go to Papua New Guinea
that they will be protected that they
will not be in harm's way and it's
Australia guaranteeing that by
outsourcing this what is happening under
this arrangement is that Papua New
Guinea which is a signatory to the
refugees convention is saying we
undertake to abide by our obligations
under that convention Papua New Guinea
needs support to increase its capacity
to deal with this and that is part of
the arrangements that Australia is
putting in place you've been eating
what's going on in Papua New Guinea
though this is a matter of PNG law this
is an area of PNG sovereignty what we
are doing is ensuring that we can
provide through development assistance
and through other support mechanisms
assistance to enable Papua New Guinea to
improve in areas where it currently
perhaps doesn't have the capacities to
quite the degree that it believes it
should but it is made very clear as the
prime minister of Papua New Guinea and
our prime minister did during the press
conference in mid-july in Brisbane this
is a commitment that PNG has entered
upon in full knowledge of the
obligations that it has and that is to
ensure effective protection for these
people if found to be genuine refugees
I'm wondering what happens to someone
coming from let's say an Islamic country
who's gay or who's a lesbian and they
want to come to Australia because
they're being persecuted because of
their sexuality and they want to come to
Australia but instead they're sent to
Papua New Guinea Papua New Guinea told
the United Nations in 2011 that it would
not decriminalize homosexuality men who
engage in same-sex sexual behavior are
penalized up to 14 years in prison so
you cannot guarantee that the legal
system in Papua New Guinea will protect
minorities the way it would in Australia
what I think you're losing sight of here
is that we are talking about a small
group of people who arrive in irregular
manner by boat give it true it's not
only versus mode answer but the point is
there are avenues available and I want
to go back to a point that Rona linens
made before this is our prime minister
is made clear is not a subject that any
single nation can deal with in isolation
we have seen including through the work
over the last few years of the barley
process the importance of regional
cooperation the barley process involves
countries throughout the southeast asian
and southwest Pacific region including
Australia we have seen our prime
minister say that there needs to be an
international conference because this is
not a problem unique to our region ask
people in North Africa ask people in
Syria and to come back to the point that
rylann hands made tackling some of these
issues at source by improving conditions
in country by working to overcome the
causes of people seeking to better their
life order flee persecution one part of
you have your foreign aid programs I
don't think anyone's disputing that but
obviously there are still reasons why
people are persecuted be it you know
there's sexual minorities for religion
or whatever reason I mean is this
morally is this lee economic well it may
be but my question is is this a moral
morally legitimate solution that
Australia is doing aren't the abdicating
responsibility for the people who land
on their Shores it for me it sounds like
an insane political competition in
humanity I mean the two parties are
toppling themselves with uh with new
ways of getting rid of those immigrants
and I still don't get what the real
problem years I mean he's talking about
boats and smugglers why don't they start
fighting them and then take care of them
after really cool is this is this an
admission that your Coast Guard fails in
its efforts to stop human trafficking on
the high seas you have a flown to
Australia over the vast tracts of water
that exists between us and the rest of
the world it's not a question of an
attempt to politically top people this
is an issue that has been around for a
very long time in Australia we are
talking about a segment of the flow of
people that needs to be addressed and
has got to be addressed not just by
nations but by regional and
international cooperation we have a very
good dialogue with Indonesia and indeed
one of the first things Prime Minister
Rudd did was go and visit Indonesia
because we recognize that Indonesia also
as a huge problem as a transit country
and you can't simply say you've made it
to Indonesia it's Indonesia's problem
you can't simply say we're going to take
people and return them to Indonesia and
leave it up to Indonesia I mean what
people would think in Germany for
example if people are coming into
Germany and and seeking asylum and if
the Germans said no you're not allowed
on German soil we're going to send you
to Iceland
now would that be politically acceptable
here be outrageous I mean in the end we
still have to take care of those people
and they chose to come here it'd be the
most minimal thing would be to at least
give them a chance to just just at least
stay here a little while and is it would
it be cheaper ambassador to take these
people in and integrate them into
society and the economy I mean you're
rich nation we work in 210,000 people
this year across our regular migration
which consists of skilled migration
which is one of the areas that Germany
is also investigating through family
reunion and humanitarian so nobody
should be in any doubt about Australia's
commitment we are a country built on
immigration we're a country built on a
simulation of people and a respect for
their cultural backgrounds and their
beliefs fifty percent of the australian
population has a migration background
the question we are talking about here
is what is one of a number of measures
that's needed to tackle a very specific
component of a problem and the
undertaking in this refugee settlement
arrangement is that people who seek
through irregular means to escape
persecution will be processed their
cases will be reviewed but insistent
with UNHCR they buy over to come to
Austria they will be able to find a
place of effective protection but if you
think that Australia burns it that's
circumventing the processes paying
people smugglers who promised you a
solution that they can't deliver is the
way to go yeah but that's what this
policy so seeking asylum I usually don't
have the money to have proper ways of
transportation that's why there are
those along at this point I know whether
they get the money from the pious I'll
as people smugglers but the point of
this policy is these people do not have
the option of coming to Australia are we
honest about that they cannot come to
Australia the Prime Minister has made it
very clear that unauthorized maritime
arrivals reaching Australian waters
after the 19th of July will be processed
with
you if their claims to asylum are found
to be valid to being resettled in Papua
New Guinea or in Nauru or if this set of
arrangements is expanded elsewhere t
look that will be what will happen
really quickly we have to move on could
you can explain what an authorised
maritime arrival would be I'm talking
about those who come through the UNHCR
or the IOM processes people arrived in
Australia through legitimate orderly
managed means where they a process
through UNHCR facilities in other
countries if they are found to be
genuine refugees Australia bears its
fair share of the burden in saying we
have a program this year 20,000 people
it's been increased from 13,700 so we
stand ready to in further increase that
humanitarian intake that's the
difference between orderly asylum
seeking processes and those who simply
try to find a shortcut using
unscrupulous properties we have to move
on it is a final question I know we have
an election that's been called for next
month the timing of this obviously looks
rather suspicious this news policy we've
got an election coming in you know is Mr
Rudd hoping that by defending the
borders of Australia from boat people
he's going to win some votes I think it
looks suspicious too cynical minds I
think this is Annie competitions are
known for being cynical well journalists
are perhaps also let's say skeptical
beautiful appraisers of fact sequence
but the important thing is that this is
not a new issue in Australia's political
history we have seen a dramatic increase
in the last few months in the number of
attempted arrivals by boat and a
dramatic increase in the number of
drownings nobody could simply say well
we can't do anything about this for fear
that people might think we're trying to
politicize it that is not a moral or a
responsibly we ensure that we've got to
be voted upon my producer saying we have
to move on we're going to run out of
time I was in Amsterdam this past
weekend and I spoke with a lot of locals
about the pros and cons of legalized
marijuana there of course there are
plenty of coffee shops to have that
conversation and as you probably know
you won't find many people who think
that the future would be better if there
were more controls on pot or similar
drugs across the globe and especially in
Uruguay they are making the Dutch
look almost old fashioned in Uruguay a
joint is about to become as legal as a
cigarette paraguay looks set to become
the first country to legalize the
production sale and consumption of
marijuana for recreational use the bill
has already passed the lower house and
is on its way to the Senate for final
approval despite quite small size the
country has a population of just three
million people experts say this
experiment could have far-reaching
consequences if other countries in the
region follow eric wise lead the US
states of Washington and Colorado have
already adopted similar laws there the
marijuana business is booming as there
is no lack of demand right and what do
you say to this and what's happening in
Uruguay is it about time really overdue
oh it's since 50 years we have this
discussion and I would say it's good
that they will begin with it Amsterdam
has begun with it and i think this
walkway and thing is very important for
the south american all the north
american people they will begin with it
ending the war on trucks are you
surprised that this is coming from south
america it's almost a little
counterintuitive right we would think it
would come from from Europe you know
Amsterdam being the example but it's
coming from South America how do you
explain not really because they are
producing the drugs mostly and therefore
they have the problems bigger than other
countries as United States also
especially and therefore they are really
the the people who are suffering from
this war on drugs the United States has
failed of course which allah people
would say has failed in the war and
George the United States has been
funneling in a lot of money to Uruguay
to get this legislation passed there are
some people who say that you're
is being used as a test case and to see
what happens when marijuana is legalized
do you think that we are going to see a
movement across the world where
marijuana is going to become as
commonplace or as legal as tobacco I
don't know that would be got a good all
instead of instead of alcohol I would
say that's more important than the
cigarettes I don't know if this
development in America is influencing
our situation in Europe that's it was
quite distinct from that so I think it's
a signal but I don't know that that we
will discuss it the tear loser being
broken though what with this type of
legislation well I mean finally I mean
it's a as you mentioned the drug war has
failed it has never worked and it's it's
proven that instead of fighting drugs
it's way cheaper it's way more effective
and it's better to invest in prevention
and treatment and also and ya better
education about the Ambassador would
this be something for Australia highly
unlikely you don't see people smoking
joints in Sydney on the street don't see
them smoking joints in Sydney on the
street there might be other parts of the
country where where they smoke them but
no we have a we have a National Drug
Strategy which is focused on three
pillars of demand reduction supply
reduction and harm reduction and I think
education is an incredibly important
part we're seeing this in Australia with
regard to tobacco for example where we
have been in the forefront of
introducing plain packaging regulation
which according to the experts has had a
measurable effect on reducing demand for
tobacco the question to me is whether or
not an approach such as is being
contemplated in Uruguay is going to
expand the problem or reduce well they
may reduce I'm cigarette sales and it
may increase joint cells I mean there
are reports that the big tobacco
companies are already inquiring in
Uruguay about setting up
big weed companies instead of big
tobacco companies I mean the great thing
about yoga is that it's legal now so
that people can grow it themselves they
can they can grow their own medicine in
the back garden I mean that's why in the
West especially just look at Big Pharma
that they hate the idea of free drugs as
you can get home and I'm rinder I mean
you know you've been a man who has known
pot for a long time is when you look
back with your experiences with it and
you've known lots of people who have
used drugs is it as harmless as it's
being made to seem in Uruguay I'm your
man with a lot of experience I would say
it's the best drug the best soft rock we
have and in in in relation to alcohol
especially it's much more better of
course we know that but we are not used
to it and therefore they are saying no
alcohol we know and that we don't know
but after 50 years we can say we know it
and therefore I would say it's much more
better did you say everybody needs to be
able to smoke a joint now and then of
course I mean and compared to two backs
I it I mean competitor backhoe tobacco
is way more harmful than any other drug
yeah except maybe sugar or something so
it's it's amazing that in the West
tobacco is legal and Marianas Italy it
is an excellent point you know I grew up
in this us south and you know on a
tobacco plantation and we know tobacco
kills people but it was considered
completely normal but no one would have
thought about marijuana and now it's
changing and now you're asking me Reiner
I'm you know you're telling me I should
try a joint sometimes you know it wasn't
that long ago when you know US
presidential candidates could have to
drop out of the race if they admitted to
smoking a joint I mean thing things have
changed
and it's still we were mentioning the
drug war this dog was still going on and
look at Obama I mean he admitted that he
smoked a joint several dress but the way
there was a pothead in his in his
college view it is a pothead every
college and if the fact that the fun
fact is that he if he would have been
caught smoking that he would never
become what I go down the president
president exactly and now he's
implementing the opposite policy the the
doctors do not agree with this stance
that the doctors in Uruguay the Medical
Association they are against the
legislation they say that the long-term
effects of using marijuana are still
worse than someone who has a drink every
now and then over a lifetime you know
they dispute what what you say right
alcohol instead of that I mean no I mean
any have you used to do you still smoke
marijuana right I used to ask you but
you don't smoke it anymore no why not
because I find as I found better drugs
after that it's a it's a drug for the
beginning to get out of the body to get
into other spaces of our consciousness
did you see you say if it dries it's a
drug for the beginning yeah I mean that
they're in us for beginners but see a
lot of people say it is it's the drug
that takes you to harder drugs like
heroin for example crass not again
waiter at home alcohol is a gateway drug
not not weed alcohol is a gateway drug
to what to everything else it's
interesting I mean I have observed from
the sidelines in the Netherlands this
decision to tighten up on access to
cafes there you have to prove residency
now and I'm just curious what your
senses of that is that because of
concern that the Netherlands was at risk
or Amsterdam was at risk of becoming the
magnet for people from all over does
this suggest concern about the long-term
effects societal effects health effects
the costs associated with dealing
perhaps 30 years later with cannabis
induced health problems
and when you talk about cost in a
society we're mentioning Alcohol Tobacco
the cost for that on the health of the
population it's way higher than marathon
would ever do and you mentioning studies
I mean if you're if you're a pothead and
compare that to having a drink every
once in a while of course it's more
harmful but you have to you have to
compare it on both levels I mean maybe a
pothead or alcoholic what what's what's
what's more dangerous wait that's it
what doesn't make sense in in Western
society is is this attitude we have this
instinctive attitude we had that that
marijuana is something more sinister
than alcohol or tobacco I mean that just
doesn't make sense and why can't
countries like the United States or
Australia why can't they come into the
21st century and at least admit that
tobacco and alcohol can be just as bad
if not worse than marijuana well
speaking for Australia we've already
made very clear that in the view of the
government the costs to society the cost
to the individual of dealing with the
long-term effects of tobacco are
enormous and prevention is much much
better than trying to deal with
treatment perhaps 30 or 40 years later
when issues arise and I think there's a
false arithmetic here that suggests that
because cannabis might be thus far
believed to be less damaging then
tobacco alcohol an increase in cannabis
use is somehow more acceptable than
saying we need to work on reducing the
demand for and therefore the
consequences of tobacco and alcohol and
drug use as we have a double standard
that we see an increase in using
cannabis is not acceptable but an
increase in alcohol use or tobacco use
while we don't condone it you can still
do it legally and that that's what's
going on in Western societies we have
this double standard and reiner and the
hippies led us down I mean weren't
wasn't it your generation that was going
to give us enlightened through drugs
like cannabis to show us another plane
of existence that would make life better
for us
i would say let them take all drugs and
they want to take and the second thing
educate them how to use them that's good
and not not too far for bit some rock
right let's useless we have seen it from
the prohibition experiences are and
therefore do it better education okay
that's all and quickly and also and also
tight regulations I mean careful tied
regular yeah yeah and it spares be
taxation according to our revenues
exactly so that pays funds paid for
itself prevention treatment regulation
let their joy is that fourth respect
ambassador I think it would be great if
you you know if we knew that you were
smoking a joint and there was a tax on
that joint it paid for better
immigration policies for example if she
knew that I was smoking a joint it
wouldn't be in my official capacity and
let me just say for the record I've
never smoked I've never inhaled okay
it's all he's never inhaled ladies and
gentlemen okay all right let's move on
the euro crisis bailing out southern
Europe Germany the paymaster of Europe
these are all huge topics that you think
would have people hitting the campaign
trail with zest now that the general
election here in Germany is just six
weeks away well in this hot summer
people are not talking politics for the
first time in German history non-voters
may make up the largest voting bloc
people are simply not excited about
their political system and they are
tuning out the government so how can
that be changed we're going to talk
about a young and naive approach in just
a moment but first take a look at this
German Chancellor Angela Merkel on the
campaign trail again her prospects look
good with less than two months to go a
comfortable majority for her coalition
is predicted the election has so far
failed to excite voters interest in
mainstream politics is waning to such an
extent that this time around non-voters
could comprise the biggest electoral
block growing numbers believe political
parties are more interested in power
than the welfare of citizens they
experts warn could pose a serious threat
to Germany's democracy well let's dire a
serious threat to Germany's democracy
its helo is that what we're looking at
absolutely so what are you doing to save
German democracy well I tried to to talk
about politics and political topics in a
different fashion and try to play a
character that doesn't understand the
political logics I mean just because
something is rational it's something is
a logical next step of something I mean
we're talking about the drug war about
refugee things they're human logic is
well we help them we take care of them
we take them in and then maybe we'll
help them whatever do whatever they want
it so you're taking topics like for
example the eurozone debt crisis the the
drug war and you're conducting
interviews with with politicians
politicians experts journalists and so
on and you're called you call it young
and naive because you're asking act very
simple and even naive questions yeah
because I think that's the problem with
the the media landscape they don't ask
those questions anymore and the people
they of course to get the news every day
but they don't understand the news
because they don't know the background
anymore so I try to of course talk about
the the current topic but also make sure
to try to provide a background you're
being a teacher in a way and deve
sometimes feel like you're doing kind of
like a colbert report or a jon stewart
because you're you're also being a
little satirical but with this approach
or you know right i mean you're poking
fun yeah i have the system I mean in the
end as I said I play a character so of
course yet you have to play with humor a
lot and especially when I talk to
politicians I have to you know provoke
them with not only simple questions but
but also are all satirical questions is
this needed Reiner I mean when you look
back at how things were in the 60s in
the early 70s yes a change
it's the same we are coming from really
being naive is that human what I am
saying what kind of speech they have
what kind of behavior then do we have
with each other and so on we were we
were we've we saw the world with
different eyes with naive eyes and
saying we must we must get together in
quite different way we are loving and
not always speaking in a aggressive way
with each other and I think that's a but
the fact that Jesus has to do this is
also it's almost an indictment against
what you try to do right isn't it says
that you failed I don't think so no no
it seems so yes of course because we
thought when we will want a new world
you man mankind then it must be stupid
all at once but that failed right but in
the long run we are successful now in
the net there is existing this new world
and the younger people are therefore
critical of this normal old
representative democracy and they are
trying to create for new kind of
democracy where everybody can be a
politician ambassador what do you say
about this are the politicians
responsible for for the apathy and the
just the high level of uninterested
voters we have right now i think is a
certain amount of self-help that needs
to be done as well it's too easy to sit
there and say somebody else needs to do
a better job but if people don't take an
interest if people don't actually deal
themselves into the process then they
can't really just sit there and be
critical of the unacceptable or the
inadequate outcomes I have a view that
in Australia we could do
or to educate younger people to become
more active in civics to become more
informed about the choices they need to
make for voting is compulsory in
Australia it's not compulsory in Germany
and do you think that's I mean you have
a hundred percent turn out or ninety
nine percent turn out we have on average
about ninety-five percent and there are
there have been times when people would
have cheered to have been able to get
that sort of a voter turnout and the
important thing is we have a very low
level of what we call invalid votes so
people actually take it seriously it's
also easy to do mostly it's on a
saturday morning you go down to your
local school somebody's got a barbecue
set up and it's a participative thing
chillin and I mean when we talk about
voter apathy I mean maybe we have to
look at it the other way I mean
politicians maybe that's the key to
their to them to their to their doings I
mean I think Henry Ford once said the
people knew how the financial system
works that be of revolutions the next
day the point is they are I think they
are glad that people like that so little
people actually are interested
interested in if you have less lobbying
going now but you see don't you think of
the Australians have got it right with
this it's compulsory voting you don't
have a choice because in Australia
they're saying right in a democracy it's
your responsibility to vote period well
it you just have they don't have a
choice but you call it a democracy so I
don't think so I mean I think you should
only go to the voting booth if you think
you have a choice and I think that's a
huge problem here in Germany that it
next month there's a big election and
the voters can see the difference
between a Steinbrueck and a Mekel they
can't say difference between the Green
Party and it is hard i mean when you
look at what are the different where are
the charismatic intelligent leaders in
germany right now I mean you have Angela
miracle she's known for her very neat no
lead us you don't need any leaders yeah
that's not a few truck well who's going
to be in the young yeah i mean the
leaders always sounds got
authoritarian and we are like the
younger we get no the younger we are the
more anti-authoritarian well maybe so
but you need the way the system is right
now you have a chance that for example
where are where are the people coming up
who inspire people and make people want
to make the country better though I mean
in the end it's not about the players
that's about the system we have to fight
the and change the political system and
not change the political players all
right well how would you like to see the
political system changed well make it a
real democracy make it a make people not
only go to the voting booth every four
years make them participate in a real
fashion and like when you sound like the
pirate party with their liquid democracy
now no well that's one approach I
support them because they tried
something latest book but yeah I mean
it's any new politics and that's as real
the younger politics I was going to say
that that to me even in Australia the
rise of social media as part of the
political discourse has been
extraordinary you can't find a senior
serious political figure in Australia
who doesn't have a facebook who doesn't
tweet who doesn't retweet this is
something that I think is changing the
way people perceive the opportunities to
engage in it is very disruptive but you
know I just want to throw this now you
know I've lived here a long time and in
none of the years that I've lived in
Berlin has my political representative
sent me anything by mail or made a phone
call to let me know that they're there
because it doesn't care yeah I mean
that's crazy that's incredibly
irresponsible to you but they get away
with it well maybe maybe that's how the
system is supposed to work so what do
you think your series young and naive is
going to do in terms of the general
election we're running out of time here
Oh mate I don't know but I'm going to
talk to a pest I'm Rick next week and
I'm enjoying it what are you gonna ask I
don't know how can one become a
candidate for Chancellor Krista then we
th steinbrück of course is the man he
wants to replace uncle American be the
next and I'm gonna ask him how he became
the candidate and if you know how he
became that we talking about democracy
again Oh
good well gentlemen thank you very much
this was definitely a very interesting
selection of yesterday thank you all for
talking with us is going to wrap up my
agenda this week don't forget that you
can watch the show again on our website
and on YouTube and don't be shy tell us
what you think about the show the inbox
of course is always open you see the
address right there I'm Brent Gough in
Berlin join me next time when I set the
agenda
you